[Musik]
und wann haben sie das letzte mal so
richtig von ihrem recht auf freie
meinungsäußerung gebrauch gemacht
gerade eben bei einer hitzigen
politischen diskussion am
frühstückstisch gestern abend per
wütendem facebook kommentar oder gar der
guten alten form eines kritischen
leserbrief meinem heutigen gast timothy
garton ash muss sich diese frage nicht
eigens stellen denn als schriftsteller
und publizist ist die mutige ausübung
seines rechts auf meinungsfreiheit für
ihn beruf und berufung zugleich doch
sind nicht auch und gerade der
redefreiheit als fundament unserer
freien gesellschaft gewisse grenzen zu
setzen und wenn ja wie während diese in
einer zeit zu bestimmen indem
religionskritische karikaturen
internationale krisen auslösen und schon
ein einziger gedankenloser tweet einen
globalen shitstorm zu entfachen vermag
wie frei muss und wie ungezügelt darf
unsere redefreiheit in einer total
vernetzten welt sein
ich bin sehr froh diese frage heute mit
timothy garton ash besprechen zu können
er ist historiker publizist
schriftsteller lehrt als alter herr
berlin professor in oxford für
europäische studien und auch uns denn
fortan huber institut herzlich
willkommen
früher stand dieses studio hier in
berlin in dem wir sitzen in einem
anderen land ein land das sie besonders
fasziniert hat und dass sie besucht
haben
was trieb einen jungen engländer ende
der 70er jahre in die ddr ich sage immer
ich bin ein berliner im doppelten sinne
also eine schule von isaiah berlin aber
auch jemanden der vom leben von die
erfahrung in diese stadt aber auch
gerade in der ddr sehr stark geprägt ist
ich bin nach berlin gekommen um meine
doktorarbeit über berlin dritten reich
zu schreiben
mich interessierte vor allem die frage
was macht aus dem einen ein
staufenberger oder bonhoeffer ein
widerstandskämpfer und aus dem anderen
ein himmler oder ein herz
ich stellte fest dass im realtime unter
einer die kommunistische diktatur in der
ddr
diese frage wenn nicht auf so ganz
extreme weise gestellt werde deswegen
habe ich bin nicht hergekommen
ich habe in ost berlin gelebt ich habe
ein buch über die ddr geschrieben und
willst du nicht mein bruder sein wohin
ich die einreiseverbot bekamen und ein
offizielle protest der ostdeutsche
regierung
das ist die schönste rezension die je
bekommen
das freiheitsliebende menschen aber es
war dann tatsächlich so sie waren in den
archiven sie an der humboldt-universität
damals noch in der ddr und haben dann
natürlich als junger neugieriger
engländer die aufmerksamkeit des
staatssicherheit der stasi auf sich
gezogen die sie beobachtet hat die auch
eine akte über sie angelegt hat was
stand denn wenn sie die akte danach nach
dem zusammenbruch der ddr gelesen haben
in dieser akte und stand er vielleicht
sogar etwas über sie drin dass sie
selbst gar nicht über sich gewusst haben
nein das könnte ich nicht sagen aber
diese akteure gewissermaßen ein geschenk
für den zeithistorischen für den
schriftsteller dan post masopust hätte
nur sein model aber um sich so habe die
stasi akte von 306 seiten mit
unglaublich präzise wenn auch maliziöse
beschreibungen minute für minute mal was
ich vor jahren gemacht hätte
ich hab mich dann vorgenommen die
untersuchen der stasi selbst zu
untersuchen indem ich die akte
vergleiche mit meinen eigenen
tagebüchern und stelle fest wie traurig
es ist das menschliche gedächtnis aber
dann auch mit man gms also die oben
nicht informiert haben wurden vom
inoffizielle mitarbeiter und und und und
die stasi offiziell gesprochen haben und
zwar nicht als opfer anklagen sondern
als jemand der verstehen will
und daraus entstand ja dieses buch die
akte mio
die auch fisch steht das
einfühlungsvermögen hat zu verstehen wie
diese menschen zu uns würden und auch so
stasi offizieren also einen dialog
zwischen beobachtern da und beobachter
ja aber auch das verstehen und zwar wie
die mechanismen eine diktatur
funktionieren ohne ganz böse menschen
wird ein böses system es braucht nur
schwache allzu schwache menschlich
allzumenschliche menschen um ein solches
um welches system aufzubauen
wenn wir von überwachungs system oder
gar welchem system sprechen da könnten
manche menschen denken das betrifft
unsere gegenwart genauso was würden sie
denn sagen wenn man sagt google facebook
und british telecom oder die stasi
damals wer verfügte oder verfügt über
mehr kenntnisse über persönliches leben
die stasi damals oder diese konzerne
häuser die antwort ist eindeutig google
und facebook und twitter und deutsche
telekom haben im prinzip viel mehr daten
übrigens im persönlichen leben als die
stahls er dass diese information diese
daten versammlung übertrifft bei weitem
die träume eines stasi generals aber man
muss gleich dazu sagen ich ziehe kein
vergleich dafür bin ich zu serie sich
weiß was das bedeutete stasi in eine
diktatur aber potenziell ist das
natürlich eine gefahr die aus dem zu
wesen des internets und das ist mit ein
grund dass sich jetzt ein buch über die
redefreiheit schreiben auf dieses buch
werden wir noch genauer eingehen wenn
sie denn sagen dass das gefühl ständig
überwacht zu werden oder zumindest dass
die eigenen daten ständig zentralisiert
und gesammelt werden ihr rede verhalten
oder vielleicht sogar der welt
verhältnis englisch drin
ich meine es ist doch eine prägende
erfahrung wenn man so sehr angst hat vor
der stasi oder die geheimpolizei in
polen oder ungarn
dass man gar nicht spricht sondern etwas
das wichtige ist aufsteigend dahin
ich habe das sogar einmal erlebt dass
jemand einer wichtige nachricht auf eine
zigarettenpapier geschrieben hat und das
er anschließend gegessen hat sie hat
buchstäblich die eigene würde gewesen
die world natürlich prägt das und das
sagt auch es ist nicht nur wie oft
gemeint eine pflanze balance akt
zwischen privatsphäre und redefreiheit
sondern ein grad an privatheit ist
geradezu eine vorbedingung für die
redefreiheit
wenn sie jetzt die unterscheidung
zwischen privat und öffentlich als eine
sagen wir notwendige unterscheidung für
jedes freie system markieren dann könnte
man ja sagen und wie ist das heute ist
das heute nicht auch so dass diese
unterscheidung kollabiert dass das
private und das öffentliche gerade
aufgrund dieser datensammelei gar nicht
mehr so klar zu trennen nicht nur aus
dem gründe sondern auch all das was man
zu sagen
im halb privaten dem facebook schreibt
oder uploaded wird plötzlich publik und
wird so eine große überhaupt ist eine
grundeigenschaft des internets das ist
es viel leichter macht dinge publik zu
machen und viel schwieriger dinge privat
zu halten und das müssen wir ganz klar
sehen also benutzen wir die chance für
die für die redefreiheit für die
menschen kommunikation überhaupt dieses
jeder kann ja verleger werden aber aber
gucken wir auch auf diese gefahr
diese ambivalenz und die neuen
herausforderungen stehen im zentrum
ihres neuen buches redefreiheit
prinzipien für eine vernetzte welt und
da sich historiker sind und vor allem
sich mit der zeitgeschichte und auch der
gegenwarts geschichte auseinandersetzen
setzt dieses buch mit dem jahre 1989 an
ein jahr das entscheidend war für diese
stadt für deutschland für den ganzen
kontinent aber sind noch andere dingen
und seit 89 geschehen
bis heute unsere gegenwart prägen welche
ereignisse waren das 1989 für sie genau
also ich hab das nicht persönlich erlebt
in warschau und prag mit wasserfarben
der sammler revolution hier in berlin
mit dem mauerfall dass wir dachten das
sei 89
nach einem viertel jahrhundert stellt
sich heraus es gibt noch dazu drei
weitere bedeutende ereignisse die bis
jetzt unsere welt und gerade diese welt
des internets prägen zum ersten tim
berners lee ein landsmann hat ja in
jahren 89 world wide web erfunden und
dass es machte das internet so diese
unglaubliche kommunikationsmöglichkeit
zum zweiten hat sicherlich das ende des
kalten krieges mauerfall und was alles
noch auf wollte die tür zur
globalisierung geöffnet und wir leben
heute noch ganz eindeutig mit dem
weiteren folgen der globalisierung auch
auf dem gebiet der information
und last but not least im jahre 1989 hat
der ayatollah khomeini der vater soll
man wusste ausgesprochen und dies prägt
uns auch bis heute und die länder noch
den aufstand in china und den
niedergeschlagenen aufstand am tiananmen
als weiteres schluss leichen genau und
das kommt dazu und zwar mit einer
gegenseitige beeinflussung also das
massaker am tiananmen-platz war in
ostmitteleuropa sehr hilfreich ich weiß
noch wie alle gesagt haben nur kein
ternberg nur keinen termin mehr bisher
nicht in leipzig und deswegen haben
beide seiten sich friedlich verhalten
und so erhalten
an umgekehrt die chinesische
kommunistische partei hat aus dem
zerfall des kommunismus in osteuropa in
der sowjetunion viel gelernt
das lassen wir nicht zu mir scheint es
so dass es eine eine sehr große gabe mit
vier ereignissen das ganze kraft fällt
auch unserer gegenwart bestimmen zu
können
und das waren 2 freiheitsliebe der fall
der mauer
die erfindung des world wide web und
zwei gegenläufige bewegung die fahrt war
rasch dies durch oder für wasch die und
die fähigkeit chinas diese
freiheitsbewegung ein zudem ist das
gleichsam sind das die vektoren das
kräftefeld in dem wir bis heute lieben
ich glaube schon ich behaupte dass auch
in europa das was ich der veto des mutes
nenne das heißt menschen die sagen wenn
du das veröffentlichen will ist bringen
wir dich um und machen es auch
glaubwürdig angefangen mit der fatah an
salman rushdie bis zu grausame ermordung
von den journalisten von charlie hebdo
in paris und das ist eben die gefahr
diese vernetzte wird ein todesurteil
wird ganz weit in tehran rolle hk
ausgesprochen wird vollstreckt in paris
oder london
das hat nicht nur zur folge dass diese
menschen nicht mehr leben das hat ein
weitgehender einschüchterungseffekten
und ich glaube dass ihr leben wir auch
heute in europa einst selbst sind zur
aus angst aber man bekennt sich nur
ungern so selbst sind so aus angst also
es spricht nicht die eigene name aus
würden sie denn sogar eine kontinuität
sehen zwischen rasch die dann gab es
theo van gogh dann gab es die dänischen
karikaturen verliert du aber auch ein
fall wie böhme man beispielsweise wo man
sagt da passiert etwas seltsam ist ein
komiker eines landes führt zu einer
staatskrise innerhalb der türkei und
kann dank der europäischen union also
ich glaube das sind zwei verschiedene
dinge
warum ist vor allem geht bei der wert
des goldes ist die gewalt und ob diese
gewaltandrohung von islamisten kommt
oder von drogengangs in mexiko oder eben
von der italienischen mafia wie im falle
roberto saviano der kante italienischer
journalist der jetzt für jeden nur
überwacht nicht wahr unter schlimmen
bedingungen lebt hier müssen wir
liberale absoluter klarer linie ziehen
um ganz harten kompromisslos sein
denn das ist die schärfste bedrohung der
freiheit meines erachtens überhaupt in
europa bei dem mann handelt es sich um
eine eigenschaft diese vernetzte welt es
ist als ob wir alle in aller welt in
eine weltstadt leben wir sind alle
nachbarn worden
früher wenn ein solcher ehren etwas
gesagt hat in deutschland würde der
türkische präsident frage denn der
chinesische nicht darauf reagieren
jetzt kommt es sofort einen der türkei
und er versucht dann gleich in
deutschland sich einzumischen
sie nennen ja diese neue
zivilisatorische lage eine cosmopolis
eine stadt die die ganze welt umspannt
gleichermaßen
und dann ist ja auch schon ein anderer
begriff den man mit hört der des
kosmopoliten des weltbürgers wenn sie
vielleicht kurz ein einer eine idee
davon geben was diese cosmopolis so
speziell macht und wie weit sich unsere
jetzige welt kulturelle situation von
allen anderen unterscheidet
es ist eine nie vorher dagewesene welt
wo als folge der von zwei entwicklungen
der massen migration und des internets
wir sowohl physische als auch virtuelle
nachbarn geworden sind früher hätte man
gesagt wenn du so willst du wenn man in
rom lebt da halten sie sich wie die
römer aber jetzt ist die lage so in rom
leben menschen aus aller welt und was in
rom gesagt fehlt wird sofort in der
ganze welt empfangen ob pakistan
nordafghanistan so hat man eine welt wo
eben wie gesagt ein todesurteil intern
ausgesprochen wird und jemand kommt um
in paris aber auch umgekehrt ein youtube
video namens innocence der vaart
beschreibt ausführlich wie den
kalifornien aufgeladen
ansonsten über das leben das profil
genau an das wirklich dummes blödes zeug
und mehr als 50 menschen sind umgekommen
in gewaltige demonstrationen meistens in
pakistan und afghanistan
eine solche welt haben wir nie erlebt
das heißt wir müssen doch versuchen frei
nach immanuel kant und sozusagen in
richtung weltbürger gesellschaften hin
zur welt bürgergesellschaft
hinzuarbeiten was heißt dass das heißt
ein gespräch an dirlos öffnen über
prinzipien über normen wie soll es sein
und dann kommen wir dazu sagen
erst dann kommen wir dazu sagen wie
sollen diese prinzipien dann
verwirklicht werden
doch mal ganz kurz bei der cosmopolis
denn das ist ja auch etwas anderes ist
eine stadt
es ist ein städtisches lebensgefühls
sogar ein metropolitane lebensgefühl wie
sie es beschreiben ja also globale dorf
hieß es beim waschen mit clown aber ein
dorf ist klein und ziemlich homogen ich
sage das ist kein dorf st
die weltstadt und unserer berührungen in
dieser so virtuelle wie auch physische
welt statt sind oft sehr oberflächliche
natürlich ja das ist stehen
nebeneinander in der u-bahn aber es gibt
keine echte berufen
aber einmal in 10.000 kommt dann eine
ganz intensive vielleicht ist es eine
liebesgeschichte bringt das leben oder
vielleicht ist seine einer konfrontation
aber eine flüchtigkeit ja aber in seine
flugreisen sofern aber wir sind bei
weitem
also mit dem begriff cosmopolis wird bei
weitem nicht gesagt dass wir alle
kosmopoliten sind kosmopolitisch sind
sondern viele viele menschen finden das
unglaublich schwer eine große zumutung
in cosmopolis zu leben das ist ja auch
das was wir gerade sehen man kann dir
sagen identitaire bewegungen oder
nationalistische bewegungen in
frankreich in england auch in
deutschland wie sie wir sehen sind auch
bewegungen die sagen wir wollen dieses
feld städtische nicht wir wollen das
dörfliche wieder lud absolut und die
praxis wähler und die trump will die
befehle in großbritannien die tram
fehler in den vereinigen staaten die
kaczynski wählt polen
man kann auch weitergehen und da ging
kommen wir auf 89
diese globalisierung ist nicht nur
unglaublich schnell vorankommen und die
eu mit seiner vier sogenannte freiheiten
also die freizügigkeit für kapitaldienst
leistungen waren und menschen also
klassische sozusagen neoliberale
globalisierung freiheit nicht die
klassischen freiheiten von franklin
delano roosevelt in riegel freiheit vor
angst von not für religion und eben
redefreiheit
zeit haben so viele menschen ökonomisch
betroffen gemacht also wir müssen dann
sagen ganz klar
langfristig ist die emigration für
unsere wirtschaften hut aber kurzfristig
hatte sehr kosten sozial wegen der
ungleichheit und auch kulturell in der
identität bei reibungen steht ja ja und
einfach diese wandel geht so schnell und
wir sind nicht der mensch ist kein
natürlicher kosmopolit wir wählen wir
werden erst kosmopoliten durch erfahrung
durch bildung und damit würde sich auch
schon die frage eröffnete reden so
leicht von das world wide web das steckt
erstellt haben hat die ganze welt
umspannt wir sind jetzt alle in einer
neuen kulturellen lage da könnte man
natürlich fragen wirklich alle wie viele
bewohner oder prozentual gesehen wie
viele menschen auf dieser erde sind den
teil dessen was sie cosmopolis nenner
sie haben völlig recht
und bis jetzt haben zugang zum internet
in etwa die hälfte der menschheit durch
das smartphone jetzt besonderes aber ich
sage auch im buch wir dürfen nicht rein
theoretisch reden von ein recht auf
redefreiheit sondern die menschen müssen
auch fähig sein dass in wirklichkeit
also das ist der alte satz des
philosophen der bettler hat theoretisch
das recht ein wunderbares abendessen im
hotel
für sich zu nehmen da hat es nicht
eigentlich die möglichkeit also eine
alphabetisch muss fast eine milliarde
menschen zugang zum internet
ausreichende bildung politische freiheit
und für viele milliarden noch vom
menschen fasst werden sich sind ja fast
50 prozent auf der eine oder andere
weise also in china ist es die diktatur
in afrika ist das analphabetentum und
die fehlen der internet-zugang nicht
wahr
das muss man schon sagen aber aber
tendenziell gehen wir auch in dieser
rechnung
ihr buch man kann das so verstehen dass
es eine art navigationshilfe für die
ozeane der rede vielfalt es in denen wir
derzeit uns alle bewegen
aber es ist auch eine deutung unserer
gegenwart die sagt schaut man genau hin
was an unserer politischen konstellation
derzeit anders ist und früher hat die
politische philosophie das verhältnis
des bürgers zu seinem start und der
staaten zueinander bedacht sie sagen wir
müssen vielmehr bedenken denn es gibt
andere player die mindestens so wichtig
sind wie die staaten genau also erstmal
zur navigation
ich benutze ein bild von michel foucault
der ein persischer dass da ein
störrischer philosophie lodes gesagt
haben soll weiß genau wir lernen wir
sollen die parisi die redefreiheit lern
und lernen wie die navigation und ich
finde es ein sehr schönes bild wie
finden wir den weg über diese neue ozean
des internets mit viele schöne
möglichkeiten aber auch viele stürmer
und sie haben das wort schützt und
gebrauchte und viele schützt uns ja also
wer entscheidet was sie und ich oder der
mensch in china oder russland oder
ägypten
hören kann und sagen kann ich sage es
gibt die große hunde die großkatzen und
wer die mäuse die große hunde sind die
staaten und die sind immer noch sehr
bedeutend also die nationalregierung
aber die große katzen sind google und
facebook und twitter und wie sie alle
heißen großen e tron und eben dieser wie
ich das beschreibe private supermächte
entscheiden im falle facebooks für 1,7
milliarden menschen wäre facebook ein
staat das wäre der größte stadt der welt
größer als china und die entscheiden
eigenständig gewissermaßen insgeheim
ohne öffentliche kontrolle oder
transparenz was man sehen davon was man
nicht sehen darf ein schnelles beispiel
es würde neulich von dem facebook seite
eines bekannten norwegischen
journalisten das berühmte foto von das
vierte mädchen ein schreiendes kind von
japan
der brand in werten im vietnamkrieg weil
eben die nackt war gegen japan war sie
nacht
das würde willkürlich von seiner seite
entfernt und sein konto würde
suspendiert darauf gab es große proteste
und und es ist hoch theken gemacht
worden aber für diese einer bekannten
fall gibt es sicherlich zehntausende die
überhaupt nicht bekannt sind
also wir müssen genauso viel unseres
engagement des bürger engagement unserer
aufmerksamkeit auf diesen großen katzen
lenken als auf den großen kunden und wir
können das auch weil wir nicht nur mäuse
sind oder sein sollen sondern wir
könnten auch vernetzte morris also
bleibt er doch mal bei diesen
wunderbaren beispiel dass sie genannt
haben da wird ein bild gelöscht weil es
ein nacktes mädchen zeigt dass eine sehr
berühmte fotografiert da gibt es zwei
fragen wie man sicherstellen kann wird
nicht auch quasi unter der hand eine
gewisse kulturelle vorahnung davon was
legitim und opportun ist zum beispiel
mit nacktheit wird dann nicht ein
amerikanisches verständnis von nacktheit
quasi global vorausgesetzt das wäre die
eine frage wird die amerikanische kultur
das kulturelle empfinden global normativ
und die andere frage wo wird denn sowas
eigentlich gelöscht wird er in norwegen
gewischt gelöscht wird ein dublin
gelöscht wird da in stanford gelöst gibt
es überhaupt ein ort wie entscheiden
wird von einem junger mann oder junge
frau der möglicherweise im silicon
valley sitzt oder in irland oder war
auch immer das ist eine virtuelle welt
aber es wird eigenhändig entschieden und
ich glaube sie haben schon recht weil
facebook davon ausgeht dass diese 1,7
milliarden menschen eine community sind
community sagt man eine gemeinschaft was
sehr fragwürdig ist
versuchen sie einheitlichen regnen und
das sind zum großen teil auch
amerikanischen kultur also keine nackten
die franzosen beispielsweise das sind
viel gelassener was die nacktheit
anbelangt ja ja ja sie versuchen sogar
den muslimischen frauen zu überzeugen
die burkinis abziehen oder diese weise
beispielsweise dafür aber viel weniger
gelassen
bei der frage der sogenannten haßberge
hate speech
insofern haben sie völlig recht und das
sollen wir auch diskutieren wobei wenn
wir dann sagen ihr sollt die nationaler
normen respektieren
dann freut sich natürlich china denn
china stehen auf eine neo westfälische
position das heil und sagt information
zu wollen
das ist geradezu ein begriff jetzt der
chinesische politik und china will die
kommunistische partei chinas nicht die
menschen eine welt wo die souveränität
wieder hergestellt wird auf dem ganzen
gebiet der informationen wollen wir das
wirklich
aber es ist ja auch eine bewegung wo man
sagt es ist das wesen dieser konzerne
nationale grenzen zu überschreiten
nationaler souveränität auszuhebeln und
die chinesische version ist wir wollen
den raum des internets in den räumen im
raum des nationalen gehalten und steuern
das heißt eine anhebung dieser dynamik
verstehe ich das richtig natürlich
genauso und zwar und das ist weil das
sind ja große kämpfe das sind macht
macht kämpfer die wir leben im jahr 2000
hat der damalige präsident bill clinton
gesagt wird ein ebt von flori internet
ist laut trainer mitchell sowohl also im
deutschen sagt manke pudding an die wand
nageln pudding an die wand
wo ist das und da dreht sich die
kommunistische partei chinas und sagt
will
gucken sie nur zu wir machen das und mit
die die beschreibung ausführlichen burg
mit dem wohl größtes sind zur apparat
der menschheitsgeschichte
denn es gibt einfach so viel mehr rede
expression im internet man braucht diese
riesige zensur apparat kriegen sie das
noch ziemlich hin
die wackelpudding wird an der wand
genagelt und das wollen wir natürlich
auch nicht
also wir wollen nicht amerikanischer
kultur normen willkürlich ohne ein
klagemöglichkeit ohne transparenz
sozusagen aufgeladen bekommen aber wir
wollen auch nicht dass die chinesische
kommunistische partei
die kontrolle über alles viele herstellt
aber es fällt ja dann doch auf das
sozusagen die großen player die sie
katzen nennen alle aus amerika kommen es
gibt gerade in europa ein steigendes
bewusstsein dafür
wir können das so nicht zulassen weil da
auch noch ein hintergedanke ist nicht
nur das was im netz geschieht ist
amerikanischer patrone sondern die
netzneutralität selbst ist
institutionell auch weitgehend in
nordamerika angesehen haben da würde ich
sehr vorsichtig sein weil ich glaube die
netzneutralität ist in der tat ein
transkultureller norm die wir auch
verteidigen die sorgen änderung
gesprochen jeder hat die gleichen zugang
und die gleiche geschwindigkeit ist ein
anti diskriminierungs prinzip ja keiner
keinen kleine keine viren diskriminiert
und ich würde davon waren diese
unterschiede so hoch zu stilisieren
wie der österreichische student max
schrems der warum man bekannterweise
gegen fast facebook geklaut hat und
seine website heißt bezeichnenderweise
europe gegen facebooks europa gegen
facebook das ist eine ganz interessante
formulierung nicht für europa gegen
facebook aber die privat schutz der
privatsphäre ist auch ein amerikanischer
ich würde also davor warnen dies dieses
hoch so stelle sich also sagen kampf der
kultur weil sie doch ganz sagen würden
dass es ein transatlantischer westlichen
letztlich die gleichen werte vertritt
und bewahren wissen sie was ich bin für
dieses buch das produkt zehnjährige
arbeit ich bin überall hingekommen nach
china nach indien nach ägypten in der
türkei und und es gibt natürlich
bedeutet und
ge in dem was richtigen ist nur
erscheint in den verschiedenen kulturen
aber diese angst um die privatsphäre
oder die verlorene privatheit ist fast
universell ja nicht nur europäer sondern
wir europäer haben allerdings in der
europäische union und in europa
wenn im europarat gewisse möglichkeiten
effektiv zu handeln weil alle auch die
größten katzen vor allem zugang für die
größte binnenmarkt der welt
wir sprachen jetzt über die hunde die
großen staaten oder staatengemeinschaft
und die katzen die globalen super
konzerne und vielleicht sollten wir die
mäuse dann doch nicht ganz vergessen
nehmen wir mal ein beispiel was die
mäuse können gerade mit dem netz es wird
ja immer gesagt die arabische revolution
war auch ein revolution deren
geschwindigkeit und intensität sich über
soziale medien transportierte und von
ihr erweckt wurde
würden sie da sagen ersten als
historiker das ist ein mythos oder das
stimmt und die zweite frage die sich
daran anschließt zeigt sich da nicht
auch wie schnell beschleunigung
irrationalität und und steuerbarkeit
kind es ist immer falsch zu meinen ist
gbm automatismus die von einer
technologie ausgeht
das hat man immer wieder solche hoffnung
gehegt dass de telegraaf am ballon was
das telefon an geht dann dann die faqs
können sie sich noch der mief aktion das
war die werde das war mir sehr sicher
bei einer artikeln als 90 fax roncalli
brach das fast befreit sie und genau das
gleiche
die gleiche fehler gemacht im hinblick
des internets allein macht es das nicht
in der arabische holen war es das
zusammenspiel von social media facebook
und und und
so genannte alte medien vor allem das
fernsehen alte serie und ein ganz alter
faktor dass die menschen bereit waren
ihr eigenes leben zu riskieren indem ihr
immer wieder zur tahrir platz kommen
damit würden sie sehr gut kurzum mut und
mein letztes kapitel wird auch der mut
wäre ist es klassische satz das
geheimnis des glücks sei die freiheiten
des gashahnes der freiheit sein
kommt ihr doch mal zu diesem buch das
der viel mehr ist als ein buch es ist
ein globales projekt wie sie sagen ein
projekt das sich über eine webseite auch
ein globalen diskurs anregen will diese
webseite heißt free speech die bate dort
org wir haben sie dort auf dot com
hier sehen sie hier es ist tatsächlich
ein globales projekt das sind 13
sprachen gleichzeitig läuft und der name
ist ja schon interessant free speech die
welt das heißt es geht nicht nur um die
ausübung der freien rede sondern eine
debatte darüber welchen prinzipien und
normen diese freie rede global zu
gehorchen hat genau und dieses projekt
geht zu wie vielen jahren in eben 13
sprachen und das projekt mache ich auch
ganz bewusst als englische europäer
das sollen wir gerade in diesen zeiten
nachbar exit betonen weil wir europäer
leben in einem zunehmend nicht westliche
oder post festlicher und sicherlich post
europäische welt vom andere mächte
andere auch andere kulturen die agenda
der weltpolitik bestimmen und dann ist
die frage welche haltung nehmen wir ein
rein defensiv in dem wir sagen wir
verteidigen unsere westlicher wärter
gegen die usa china und und und oder
haben wir das vertrauen an den an der
universalismus unsere werte
an ihrer attraktion an ihre gültigkeit
dass wir eher offensiv aber auch mit
offenen ohren raus gehen wie ich das
mache und empfehle und sagen hier sind
unsere vorschläge wie wir uns verhalten
sollten wir uns einigen sollten auf
welchen grundprinzipien wir uns einigen
sollten
aber wir hören auch zu wir wissen dass
auch in der indischen kultur in der
chinesische kultur auch in der welt des
islams sehr interessante denkanstoß der
ist sehr interessante denkanstöße gibt
wie bei der kaiser artikel zum beispiel
weise in indien oder auch bei konfuzius
und da wollen wir durchaus auch zu hören
und im dialog also es auch von der tiefe
geleitet dass in jeder kultur es strenge
gibt die das was wir die werte der
aufklärung nennen heutzutage schon im
keim angelegt sind und die man wieder
beleben muss gleich sah und die sie
selber wieder beleben wollen ich zitiere
zum beispiel ein protest von den
sogenannten neo konfusion in china gegen
einer wirklich radikale brutale sensor
eine bekannte liberale wochenzeitung in
china dieses protest beruft sich nicht
etwa auf die menschenrechtserklärung des
rollos oder die aufklärung sondern
beruft sich auf konfuzius aufstellen der
konfuse der gerade das müssen wir dann
wollen und wir kommen also im gespräch
und haben dann selber eine bestimmte
gratwanderung oder balance sagt und
dieses die balance akt von eiser
airberlin dass ein philosoph muss man
dazu erklären ein britischer philosoph
der aus russland nach england
integrierte und der ein großer denker
ein liberaler denker der freiheit war
denn ich hätte den großen luftigen
person nicht gut zu kennen und von dem
ich sehr beeinflusst war
der immer diese kombination suchte
zwischen einer wirklich prinzipiellen
standfesten liberalismus und ein werte
pluralismus und auch eine kulturelle
oder transkulturelle sensibilität und
das ist es gerade was ich versuche in
diesem klarzustellen wo sind die
fundamentale liberale prinzipien wo man
kein kompromiss eingehen darf da essen
phase zum beispiel die frage nackte
gewalt oder der gleichberechtigung und
die themen wo man sehr genau hinhört und
versucht und vielleicht kann man das
auch anders machen
es gibt ja nur zwei gründe warum
menschen miteinander reden
der eine ist man will sich einig werden
und der andere ist man will wissen was
der andere denkt und strebt einigkeit
gar nicht erst an würden sie sagen dass
free speech die paid dot org er den
kontrast als den konsens sucht oder
streben sie und erwarten sie letztlich
auch ein konsens in diesem prozess hier
suchen was wir natürlich nie erreichen
werden
gut sind die menschen so ist die welt
aber wir suchen ein minimalkonsens
darüber wir wären einige bleiben
das heißt das ist klassische liberale
antwort den rahmen sowie bei kant nicht
wahr
wir wollen keinesfalls keinesfalls
konflikt in die zwischenmenschlichen
konflikte also werte konflikte enden
das wäre wie kann selbe sagte ein blödes
schäfer leben nein aber wir wollen dies
regeln und fröhlich halten und das ist
das ist nicht besonders originell ist
nur die umstände haben sich so radikal
geändert uns fällt jetzt müssen wir
nicht nur theoretisch sondern auch
praktisch dieser regeln eine welt
bürgergesellschaft global so
wie sehen sie denn in diesem prozess als
das größte hindernis ich mach mal ein
vorschlag als weißer mitteleuropäer des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts ist man
zum beispiel eher nicht stark religiös
geprägt wir alle sind in einer art post
religiösen bewusstsein und am
geisteszustand und wir vergessen dabei
dass große teile der welt nach wie vor
stark religiös geprägt sind ist das
nicht vor allem eines dieser
spannungsfelder dass wir in unserer
kultur gar kein rechtes verständnis mehr
von der macht und der tiefe religiöser
überzeugungen erwecken können ja ja wir
hatten es gerade gewissermaßen oder so
schien es uns vergessen und zwar in den
sechziger und siebziger jahren des
vorigen jahrhunderts und dann kam es
wieder in form des islams zb bei
habermas sehr interessant denn in seiner
erste arbeiten zur öffentlichkeit kommt
der religion komfort und jetzt musste
also danach ruht mittlerweile sehr
theoretisch sehr daran interessiert hier
ja aber aber eben auch aus dem grunde
das sei eine lücke gesehen hat natürlich
also sinn dieses experiments das ist
natürlich ein experiment einen prozess
also das buch ist auch eine einladung
zur weitere debatte ist herauszufinden
wo sind die gemeinsamkeiten ich habe
schon einige genannt schutz der
privatsphäre die gefahren die aus der
anonymität im netz kommen
aber wo sind die große unterschiede und
die sind unterschiedlich geartet in
china ist die religion an sich keine
sehr große gern sehr großes problem aber
natürlich im nahen osten oder in indien
wird sofort sehr stark reagiert dieses
buch ist ja eine art zehn prinzipien
will jetzt nicht sagen zehn gebote habe
das doch sehr handlich in zehn
prinzipien restrukturiert und ein
prinzip betrifft auch die religion ist
es das prinzip 6 und bei sie ja sagen es
ist der anfang einer konversation nicht
als ende die sich dieses prinzip mal vor
dass sie
genannt haben für die religion im umgang
mit der globalen rede- und
meinungsfreiheit dieses prinzip lautet
wir respektieren alle gläubigen aber
nicht unbedingt alle glaubensinhalte
genau jetzt kann man sich natürlich
fragen aus der sicht eines gläubigen
menschen kann ich diese trennung
überhaupt machen ist mein personale
identität mein welt zugang nicht ganz
ganz eng verbunden mit den inhalten
meines glaubens ist das eine brauchbare
trennung so sie haben völlig recht wir
haben sehr lange an diesem prinzip
gearbeitet in der tiefe diskussion
letztendlich haben sich geeinigt
wenn nur schwer mein kollege wünsche
dawkins der bekannte atheist der
theologieprofessor auch aus meiner
universität in oxford ohne eine
islamische theologie an eine geworden zu
diesem prinzip
aber man muss gleich dazu sagen alle
gläubigen nicht nur muslime finden das
schwer
auch der katholik wurde der protest
findet es schwer zu sagen wie kannst du
mich respektieren wenn du nicht meinen
glauben was passiert ist nur wenn wir
weiter gehen und sagen daher mussten wir
alle religions- inhalten auch das
controlling oder auch dämonen oder was
es auch nur gibt denn denn wir können
doch nicht zwischen ordentlichen ohne
ordentliche religion unterscheiden ja
das muss ja weisungen die glaube geht
muss es ja selbst objektive definiert
definiert werden
wenn wir dann in diese vernetzte welt in
dieser cosmopolis aller tabus von aller
religionen und alle glaubenssysteme
zusammennehmen um sagen
darüber können wir nicht frei reden dann
gibt es herzlich wenig wo überhaupt
sprechen
also diese unterscheiden müssen wir
müssen daran festhalten
zwischen 1 ich betone bedingungslose
respekt bedingungslos respekt für den
glauben in seinen ganzen menschheit ist
seine ganze qualität und das was wir im
westen erst mit der aufklärung in den
schweren kämpfen errungen haben die
möglichkeit kritisch über alle
glaubensinhalte einschließlich der
atheistischen soeben haben wir es doch
noch ganz konkretes gab jahren fall
vielleicht der bekannteste fall der
letzten jahre die mohammed-karikaturen
der dänischen zeitung wo man sagen
könnte und das würde mich interessieren
wenn sie dieses prinzip auf diesen fall
anwenden ist das eine respekt der
gläubigen aber nicht unbedingt der
glaubensinhalte oder wird ein gläubiger
mit dieser karikatur der abbildung
mohammeds vielleicht auch mit einer
bombe oder eine handgranate nicht schon
auch selbst verletzt was würden sie
sagen naja die karikaturen war auch sehr
unterschiedlich nicht fahren manchmal
manche haben auch die islamkritik
kritisiert ich würde erstmal sagen seit
juni seit der antike ist dieser türe an
ein sondergebiet ja auch im alten athen
an die ganz besondere es waren die
narrenfreiheit nicht war aber dann dazu
also jemand kann nicht sagen dass es
eine gut informierte durch die kritik
werde an an dem islam
aber ich hätte diese karikaturen unter
normalen umständen nicht abgedruckt oder
wieder abgedruckt im guardian of the
band boten sonsten denn das ist nicht
mein verständnis von
zusammen neben den inhaber aber wenn es
um veto des models kommt wenn es also um
die gewalt dann habe ich ausdrücklich
dafür plädiert in hinter in sachen
charlie du dass zeitungen und
zeitschriften in eine koordinierte
aktion ausgewählte karikaturen neu
abdrucken auf der innenseite mit einer
erklärung warum wir das machen also dann
ließen die frage der gewalt und der
verteidigung um gegen das veto des
mörders und nicht um die frage der
glaubensinhalte wir sehen hier und da
sie sagten das ja schon die satire ist
ein wichtiges momente auch totalitäre
macht zu untergraben
ihr landsmann ortschefs berry hat man
von der wahrheit' probe der
lächerlichkeit gesprochen ist dass wir
die freie rede vielleicht auch ein ganz
zentrales moment das man über die dinge
lachen können muss auch über die eigene
ja natürlich ich zitiere ich habe ein
ganzes ab sommer über über humor und wie
wichtig humor ist mit uns ein paar sehr
gute witze wie ich finde ja denn ich
zitiere da am aus hollister sagt er habe
nie ein fanatiker getroffen mit einem
sinn für humor und nie einen menschen
mit einem sinn für humor der ein
fanatiker wird und deswegen möchte er
humor tabletten produzieren und ganzen
nahen osten verbreiten werde nicht wahr
das finde ich finde das unglaublich und
das sind schöne zitat des sie bringen
und bei was ich jetzt für eine wirklich
eine krankheit unsere zeit nämlich wie
schnell menschen beleidigt werden nur
ein wort falsche stelle auf meine
studenten in oxford minister sofort
beleidigt der eilige
wir wollen ein safe space eine sichere
zonen haben wir diese beleidigung wo
bleibt dieses dass dieses hella blick
hast diese gelassenheit sich selbst
gegenüber und dem anderen und dann würde
man ja sagen okay da ist ja auch eine
flucht in der politiker korrekten die
macht den raum des sagbaren eng und
führt an und das führt auf prinzip
fünfter sie sagen zu einem verlust
dessen was sie robuste zivilität nennen
die wir alle an den tag legen sind kann
ich das mit kränkung resistenz
übersetzen wir müssen sehen dass wir
nicht zu leicht gekränkt werden ja
ungleich zeit mussten wir gegen das was
ich enge gezogen nicht hassrede sonnen
gefährlicher reden nennen müssen wir uns
werben wenn es wirklich gefährlich wird
für eine minderheit ob sexuelle
orientierung oder ethnisch oder religiös
da mussten wir auch ganz stark
eingreifen als zivilgesellschaft und als
staat aber was wenn es sonst ich hole
dann haben die das findet er eine sehr
schöne übersetzungen und dass die da
kommen wir auf die navigation zurück ja
wir wollen wir steuern den weg in dieses
ozean von grobheiten und und und auch
sehr ungezogen der grobe beschimpfung
und nicht wahr indem wir mit eine
gewisse gelassenheit fortfahren und dem
wir sozusagen in der zivilgesellschaft
dieser robuste zivilität praktizieren
aber es robuste zivilität ich finde es
sehr schön wenn sie sagen dass hinzu
aquatische metaphern wir sind auf hoher
see
wir müssen uns wie sie leute orientieren
was die leute brauchen sind ja nicht
starre regeln sondern orientierende
faustregeln die eine gewisse grund
flexibilität haben verstehen sie riecht
dass die art der regeln die wir in der
jetzigen situation brauchen nicht zu
starr sein dürfen sondern dass sie
selbst um sozusagen eine innere
flexibilität in sich tragen müssen
genau sie haben das besser gesagt als
wir hier sagen konnte und zwar sind es
keine rechtlichen vorsätze
und das recht ist ja jeweils andere
seite das ist genau aber was man auch
zum see fahren braucht ist natürlich
erfahrung und das problem dass wir in
europa haben ist dass wir zu schnell zum
vater starb ergreifen und sagen der
staat muss beispielsweise in die
heckflossen israel der ja keine schön
dass selbst ein etwas hässliches wort
ich finde kein anderes der staat muss
sozusagen zivilität erzwingen wir sind
damit meines erachtens nicht sehr gut
gefahren
ich stelle das einfach rein enthüllung
ist frankreich ist keine viel zivile
gesellschaft als die vereinten staaten
obwohl frankreich sehr viele hassrede
gesetze hat und die vereinigten staaten
keiner um diese diese gruppe um diese
diese wege über dem bundes hohen see zu
finden müssen wir auch erfahrungen haben
so haben die seeleute es gelernt
wir müssen uns auf dieses mehr der
redefreiheit selbst in auslagen hinaus
wagen sollen und ich jetzt zähle eine
ganz interessante geschichte wenn ich
das kurz erwähnen darf ein französische
lehrer erzählt mir vor unglück
geschichte unterrichtsstunde uwe
holocaust auschwitz dann hätte eine so
entsetzliche witz irgendwie gefrustet
dass ich das gar nicht viele geben
möchte dreht sich zornig um als mau aber
am nächsten tag kommt er zurück und sagt
ich möchte mit euch darüber diskutieren
was sie gesagt haben zu paulo kommt wohl
stimmt die schule sagen folgendes aber
herr lehre
viele professoren das dürfen wir nicht
sonst mussten sie uns gleich anzeigen
willkommen vor gericht weil das gesetz
regelt er für sich nein nein das bleibt
unter uns hier den vier wänden
und dann ergibt sich eine offene robuste
diskussion und am ende sagen die schule
wir danken ihnen sehr herzlich für
dieses gespräch das ist das erste mal
dass wir darüber diskutieren könnten
und wir verstehen warum das falsch war
diese wird zu erzählen und das wäre
jetzt ein beispiel für die sache
staatliche verordnung und freiheits
räume des gesprächs die von diesen
staatlichen geboten unbelastet gleitende
aber strukturierte freiheits raum
das robuste zivilität ja und gerade in
der schule unter nennung in der
universitäten denn eine andere
eigenschaften sind netz ist diese kokam
effekt dieses starke akku kamera sagt
jede kindheit ist ein effekt am hahn
jetzt als erwachsener leben wir alle in
eco kammer also die donkey kong kammern
oder die praxis der kamera aber auch
dich liberaler ego kammern schule und
universität sollten die zwischen stadion
sein wo wir das leben mit der vielfalt
auf nicht nur lernen sondern auch üben
also dass gefahr des internets
einerseits einen sehr breiten diskurs
raum zu schaffen andererseits jeder
verschließt sich in sein eigenes
gesprächen nische und dann wird keine
zivile tugend mehr möglich es stellt
sich heraus dass es ebenso zu sagen
deshalb la dvd dvd qualität essen will
das ist zu sagen wir haben gedacht dass
es gibt unglaubliche chancen für
vielfalt ja aber in diese vielfalt kann
jeder auch der norwegische massenmörder
anders behring breivik seiner
gesinnungsgenossen finden und dadurch
wird nur die wenn nur die vorurteile
immer wieder verstärkt und verstärkt sie
nannten vorhin den denker michel
foucault und sie haben sich selbst als
ein mensch und geist der aufklärung und
der werte der aufklärung bezeichnet von
foucault gibt es den satz dass das
menschliche subjekt so wie es die
aufklärung sich vorgestellt hat wie eine
figur am strand irgendwann überspült und
weggewischt wird sie sprachen auch von
einer großen kulturellen wende
sind wir in einer zeit in der das was
wir das aufgeklärt das objekt nannten es
in gefahr weggespült zu werden von einem
neuen mehr von einer neuen dynamik ist
ich glaube dass die gefahr es immer
gegeben dass es immer gegeben
[Musik]
aber wie gesagt ich bin weniger foucault
aus saal berlin und was berlin gemacht
hat ist sich nicht mit der aufklärung so
sehr zu beschäftigen mit dem denken der
aufklärungs und mit den denkende
gegenaufklärung um freien aktions töten
will die stärkste gegen elend argument
zu entdecken
und ich glaube das brauchen wir zu
machen heutzutage als mit den stärksten
gegenargumenten auch von anderen
kulturen intensiv zu beschäftigen um die
die kunden schafften die gründe rungen
schafften der aufklärung zu verteidigen
ihr projekt free speech tibet ort ist
ein aktiver beitrag dazu die lektüre
dieses buches die was ich sehr empfehlen
kann
ist es auch hergarten es die
gedankenfreiheit haben wir schon sagt
der kreis jetzt brauchen wir nur noch
die gedanken ich bin sicher heute waren
einige gedanken dabei die uns zur
freiheit und zur robustheit erziehen
können und ich danke ihnen sehr für
dieses gespräch
dankeschön kommende woche treffe ich in
der sternstunde philosophie die
schriftstellerin sibylle lewitscharoff
und sie sehen hier jetzt gleich im
anschluss den preisgekrönten
dokumentarfilm über den schweizerisch
amerikanischen fotografen robert frank
dort blinkt also nicht blinzeln und
schon gar nicht abschalten
machen sie es gut
[Musik]